[Music]
daniel golden chronicles how students
from privileged backgrounds receive
preferential treatment in gaining access
to elite colleges in his new book the
price of admission he spoke about it at
the yale bookstore in new haven
connecticut for 40 minutes
good evening and welcome to the yale
bookstore
my name is richard carlson and on behalf
of the staff i welcome you here this
evening to another in our year-round
author series
tonight we have
a provocative book
by a well-known author
every spring as students on this campus
know
thousands of
high school seniors await those letters
of admission from various universities
and colleges
around the country
but thousands of
those students who
are from lower income families
are going to learn that they have been
rejected by america's most exclusive
colleges
what they may never learn is how many
candidates like themselves
have been passed over in favor of
wealthy white students with lesser
credentials
children of alumni
big donors
or celebrities
in the price of admission how america's
ruling class buys its way into elite
colleges
and who gets left outside the gates
the pulitzer prize-winning reporter
daniel golden
argues that america the so-called land
of opportunity
is rapidly becoming an aristocracy in
which america's richest families receive
special access to elite higher education
enabling them to give their children
even more of a head start
the author of this book is deputy bureau
chief at the boston bureau of the wall
street journal
where he has covered education topics
since 1999.
previously he was a reporter at the
boston globe
the recipient of numerous journalistic
awards and honors
including the pulitzer prize
and the george polk award he holds a ba
from harvard college
he lives with his wife and son in
belmont massachusetts
tonight he's down
in the city
that
hosts yale university
and we are very honored and pleased to
have him with us this evening at the
yale bookstore and i would ask that we
all give a warm bookstore welcome
to daniel golden
[Applause]
well thanks very much for coming uh
i'm i'm glad to be here at yale i didn't
have an opportunity to come here for my
book my research didn't bring me here
because i didn't get enough tips about
unsavory goings-on and yale admissions
i don't know if that's because yale is
more meritocratic than most institutions
or because i just need better sources
here but either way i haven't been here
for a while so i'm glad to be uh to be
talking here
and i'm going to talk for a while and
then if people have questions i'll be
glad to answer those
in a 1946 essay called in front of your
nose the great english writer george
orwell described what he called the
human quote power of ignoring facts
which are obvious and unalterable
and which will have to be faced sooner
or later plain unmistakable facts sure
being shirked by people who in another
part of their mind are aware of those
facts
in my view this capacity to ignore the
obvious has long characterized the
debate over affirmative action in
college admissions
colleges and other liberal groups and
institutions defend minority preference
conservatives attack it but both sides
talk as if affirmative action is the
only or predominant admissions
preference that doesn't involve the
candidate's individual merit
actually both sides know better the
plain unmistakable facts which i lay out
in my book are that there's a whole
array of other admissions preferences
that favor wealthy white people
more applicants receive special
consideration under what i call the
preferences of privilege than under
affirmative action and in some cases the
admissions break is as big or bigger
than the one that affirmative action
confers
now i began looking into these uh
preferences of privilege pretty much by
accident in two thousand three
when the u s supreme court agreed to
hear a challenge to affirmative action
in admissions to the university of
michigan
this lawsuit was filed by white students
who'd been passed over for admission to
michigan even though they had better
records than minority students who had
been accepted
and the media had focused on the fact
that
michigan had a 100 point scale for
undergraduate admissions
and minorities received a 20-point boost
on that scale
going through the documents about the
case
i noticed that there were a lot of other
factors that gave preference on this 100
point scale
for example children of alumni received
four points and in fact one of the white
plaintiffs who was complaining about
being discriminated against was actually
an alumni child and had received that
four-point boost
and then there were many other factors
there was a 20-point boost for uh
special cases which apparently meant
quarterbacks or children of state
universe state legislators who set the
university's appropriations
so i noticed these and and started
working on a series of articles about
preferences other than affirmative
action
and i continued my research through
those articles and into uh this book the
price of admission
in the course of my thinking about it
and researching it
i identified four types of what i call
these preferences for the privileged
these preferences play a role at most
selective institutions public or private
not just yale in the ivy league but
catholic institutions like georgetown
and notre dame public institutions like
the university of michigan or the
university of virginia and other private
universities around the country from
duke to stanford
so these four preferences of privilege
include first the preference for alumni
children known as legacy preference
at yale you might call it the bush carry
preference in honor of the
two presidential candidates in the last
election
they were both yale legacies of course
and are both parents of legacy since
they've each had a child attend here
at elite institutions uh somewhere
between 10 and 25 percent of the student
body are alumni children
and generally uh that confers at sat
advantage of about 50 to 75 points on
the old uh 1600 point scale
and that advantage can be a lot bigger
if the alumnus also happens to be a
major donor
now this uh this has come under some uh
disagreement from yale's president rick
levin he defended legacy preference in
the alumni magazine here a couple years
ago and he said quote
the grades and test scores of the
legacies we admit are higher than the
average of the rest of the admitted
class
now uh that's a bit misleading like a
lot of what elite colleges say about
these preferences
the reason is that the rest of the
admitted class includes a variety of
other groups that receive preference
including athletes and underrepresented
minorities
their test scores bring down yale's
overall average so if you compare
the test score of legacies
and their grades with that of students
without preference
that is white and asian american
students who are not alumni children
don't have any other uh connection to
the university
you'd find that the legacy score i'd be
confident to predict is a bit lower than
that of the unconnected student that's
why they call it a preference after all
now the second preference of privilege
is what colleges
somewhat euphemistically called
development preference
this is not a preference about students
who are going to develop further if they
come to the university development in
this case is another word for
fundraising the development office is
the fundraising office and these are
students who are recommended by the
fundraising office even though their
parents are not alumni
because their parents or relatives are
considered to be in a position to help
the institution with money or visibility
the parents may be
corporate tycoons hollywood celebrities
or politicians in a position to provide
earmarked funding to the institution if
their children are accepted
this preference can be huge it can
amount to 300 or 400 sat points out of
1600.
to give you an example that i wrote
about in the journal and then again in
my book
in 1998 stanford uh rejected eight of
the nine it's nine applicants from the
gratin school
uh famous massachusetts prep school the
alma mater of uh franklin roosevelt
among those they rejected was henry park
a middle-class korean-american student
with a 1560 sat score and a high class
rank
the only one of the nine that they
admitted was margaret bass she had a 12
20 sat score 340 points lower than henry
and she ranked in the middle of the
groton class
one possible reason she was the only one
accepted is that her father robert bass
is a billionaire oil magnate who had
given stanford 25 million dollars and
was on the board of trustees his other
three children went to stanford again as
well as harvard and duke to all of which
he's made multi-million dollar donations
now the uh the third kind of preference
after legacy and development is athletic
preference now if you're a college
sports fan like like i am you watch a
lot of college football and basketball
on tv
and you see uh
a reasonably diverse group of athletes
racially and socioeconomically
and those sports are diverse but uh what
the television viewers don't realize is
that colleges also give admissions
breaks to athletes in many
prep school sports that ordinary
american kids never have a chance to
play
crew horseback riding sailing squash
skiing and the like
colleges uh give this athlete preference
for these sports to please uh wealthy
donors who you know rode crew or played
polo themselves
and uh
want their alma mater to have a winning
team and are willing to subsidize a
boathouse or polo ponies and so on
the uh title ix the gender diversity law
which has contributed obviously to uh
gender equity has worsened this
socioeconomic disparity because it's led
colleges to start women's teams in blue
blood sports like crew and equestrian
events while eliminating men's teams in
more middle class and working class
sports like wrestling and track and
field
the fourth one of these preferences of
privilege i i
would list is the preference for
children of faculty and administrators
i include this one because college
faculty and administrators except for a
small but increasing number of college
presidents are not multi-millionaires
but they are highly educated and since
all studies show that the children of
people with extensive education
already have an advantage in education
themselves
in test scores and the like
i don't see why they should receive a
preference
and uh these students the the children
children faculty administrators amount
to maybe two or three percent of the
student body
at a top university the blue blood
athletes who i mentioned that might be
10
if you add them all together all the
beneficiaries of these preferences you
get something approaching a third of the
student body at the typical elite
university
now you wouldn't think that these
preferences of privilege are such a big
deal i mean
nobody's getting killed in this
situation nobody's breaking any laws
maybe the worst that happens is that
somebody
who has the ability uh or the
credentials to excel at a top tier
school
ends up going to a second supposedly
second-tier school instead and maybe
somebody who doesn't quite have those
credentials ends up at one of america's
leading universities
that's not a tragedy if you just look it
in that way but on another level there's
something about these admissions perks
for the rich that violates our basic
notions of what america stands for
fairness equal opportunity and upward
mobility particularly in a time of
growing social and economic inequality
where there's an increasing gap between
the haves and the have-nots
these preferences are part of the reason
why studies show
that half to three-quarters of the
students at america's elite colleges
come from the top
fourth in income
and only about five to ten percent of
the students at the top colleges come
from the bottom fourth in income
these elite colleges most of which have
hardly increased their student body uh
size in decades
and admit only one in eight or ten
students they reserve slots for these
wealthy children of privilege while they
turn away outstanding middle class and
working-class applicants mainly white
and asian-american
as notre dame's admissions dean
mentioned to me while i was researching
this book the poor schmuck who has to
get in on his own has to walk on water
sometimes even walking on water it
doesn't seem to be enough
take the case of jamie lee
who i was lucky enough to get to know in
the course of researching the price of
admission
he achieved perfect scores on his sats
and two out of three of his sat2 subject
tests 780 on the other
top class rank a creative mathematician
a fine musician
yet he was rejected by five top schools
and waitlisted by two others
he faced the prospect of an involuntary
gap year between high school and college
until his family contacted me and i
started calling the colleges on the
waitlist
to ask why he hadn't been accepted
those two colleges were colombia and
dartmouth and dartmouth finally out of
embarrassment i believe took him off the
wait list
he's now flourishing there
another example jonathan simmons
a high school valedictorian from a
low-income family a devout catholic
nevertheless rejected by notre dame
it accepted a classmate of his name
kevin desmond who had lesser grades and
test scores than jonathan the reason uh
kevin's father grandfather three uncles
and five older siblings all went to
notre dame and the family endowed a
scholarship there
now this kind of passing over of top
students often outrages not just these
students themselves and their parents
their teachers their guidance counselors
but also the admissions staff at the
colleges
who consider themselves professionals
and they
advocate for and want to select the best
candidates often the beneficiaries are
imposed on the of preference are imposed
on these admissions offices
from the outside over the uh staff's
objections
one example uh the harrison frist the
eldest son of
outgoing lame duck majority leader
senator senator bill frist
was not in the top 20 percent of his
class at his washington dc prep school
when he applied to princeton the
admissions office gave him its lowest
ranking on its academic scale
nevertheless uh princeton's president
considered him a top priority and the
younger frist was admitted
again possible reasons he was admitted
his father is not only a famous
politician
likely presidential candidate but also
uh a princeton alumnus a former trustee
and the first family has given princeton
25 million dollars there's that number
again
and uh if any of you have visited
princeton you'll know there's a frisk
campus center
once he enrolled at princeton harrison
joined its rowdiest student club and was
promptly arrested for drunk driving
undeterred princeton admitted his
younger brother this year
similarly the application of michael
ovitz's son chris
caused a furious debate
within the brown university
administration
mr ovitz of course is a well-known
hollywood agent power broker
chris again was not in the top 20 at his
prep school
didn't take a lot of advanced classes
and the brown admission staff said
you know we're not going to stretch that
far even for the son of a hollywood
celebrity
but brown's president at the time gordon
gee
insisted
he wanted access not just to mr ovitz
himself and his wealth and importance
but also to his list of powerful clients
who he thought could bring a certain
visibility and panache to brown
chris ovitz ultimately dropped out of
brown in less than a year but brown did
benefit because michael ovitz brought
high-profile clients like martin
scorsese and dustin hoffman to brown
for well-publicized and heavily attended
campus events
my book's gotten a lot of attention for
naming these kind of names uh ovitz
frist and the like
but in most cases i don't blame the
parents or at least i don't assign the
majority of the blame to them
you know they love their children they
naturally want to give them every
advantage and it's at least perceived
that a degree from
princeton or brown will give you a leg
up in your career
the problem is that the system invites
this kind of abuse
and it and make no mistake the abuse is
systematic it's not the occasional or
unusual case
for example colleges have
institutionalized back channel routes to
admission for the rich such as harvard's
z list
students on harvard z list uh tend to be
children of uh well collected
well-connected alumni and big donors
with less than peak credentials
although they're often told in advance
that they'll be admitted they're
officially wait listed until the end of
the school year
then after their rejected classmates
have gone home and everything's quiet
they're admitted not for that september
but for the year after
and so they uh
they end up getting their goal of going
to harvard and harvard ultimately reaps
the benefits in terms of
the bottom line
now colleges conceal these kinds of
practices by perpetuating myths and half
truths
for example you'll often hear college
administrators say that legacy
preference is
valuable to maintaining college
traditions
and that may be so but it doesn't
explain why the child of a wealthy
alumnus who donates heavily gets a
bigger admissions preference than a
child of a poor alumnus who can't afford
to donate
one study of harvard admission showed
that if an alumni child who applied
needed financial aid
the legacy boost disappears almost
entirely in fact the author of the study
said to me that
the lesson he drew from this was if
harvard admitted somebody and they
weren't successful enough to pay their
own child's tuition then it wasn't going
to make the same mistake twice
or college is another uh myth or half
truth colleges boast about how many
valedictorians and students with perfect
sat scores they turn down
they give the impression we're so
selective our standards are so high that
even these valedictorians and these kids
with perfect sat scores don't measure up
academically
of course the reality is they would have
more room for valedictorians and
students with perfect test scores if so
many slots weren't taken up with
legacies development cases and the like
some college administrators who are more
candid than others
will acknowledge that these preferences
are fundraising tools
but they'll say this faustian bargain is
worth it because they need the money to
support laboratories scholarships
faculty salaries and the like
and i would certainly agree that these
kinds of uh investments in higher
education are vital
obviously laboratories faculty great
faculty
and uh scholarships are all very
important things
i would question how much money colleges
need i mean harvard's endowment is now
at 29 billion dollars and yales is at 18
billion
and how much more will a difference will
another billion make
but my main criticism of this is that
raising money by corrupting the
admissions process is taking the easy
way out it doesn't have to be the way
colleges raise money in my book i show
that uh
caltech
and two other fine schools berea college
in kentucky and cooper union in new york
city
admit their uh
students on merit and don't favor rich
candidates don't practice legacy
preference or development preference or
preference for athletes who play blue
blood sports
and yet they're still able to raise
money partly through creative approaches
to fundraising for instance gordon moore
the co-founder of intel corp
who earned his phd at caltech
later gave 600 million dollars to the
institute in tribute to what he called
in an interview with me it's quote
fantastic intellectual climate
mr moore's two sons did not go to
caltech and he had no idea of trying to
facilitate their admission
instead he received a different award
caltech named an asteroid after him and
he was tickled pink by that and it
didn't take us any admission slot from
people
of uh who warranted admission
now berea in kentucky educates the best
and the brightest of appalachia's rural
poor
it won't even accept any students from
families that earn more than fifty
thousand dollars a year
yet it's per student endowment is as big
as wellesley's and dartmouth's which
have plenty of families
earning more than fifty thousand dollars
a year sending kids there because
thousands of people across the country
alumni and non-alumni alike admire
berea's populist fervor and donate to it
with no hope of an admissions quid pro
quo
the bottom line is this if a college has
terrific programs a distinctive niche
cutting edge research and scholarship as
the ivy leagues and other elite colleges
do
then alumni and other donors i believe
will support these programs for their
own sake
i mean it will take some educating of
alumni as many of you know
yale under president kingman brewster
experimented 35 years ago with
restricting legacy preference
and it turned down the children of some
of its wealthy wealthiest alumni who
were not its strongest candidates
the alumni uh reacted furiously
particularly william f buckley
and yale uh soon restored legacy
preference under pressure from alumni
well i think enough time has passed that
it would be wonderful if yale would try
again
if not on its own then collectively with
other elite universities to diffuse a
little bit of the alumni anger
it's time for america's best
universities to eliminate the
preferences of privilege and open their
doors to the best applicants whatever
their backgrounds
now i invite whatever questions you
might have um
when you i want to ask a question wait
for uh the microphone to be brought to
you
okay go ahead hold on
yeah
hello i was wondering whether any
college presidents have so far responded
to your book
well uh there's different ways of
responding and i would like to think
that harvard's decision to eliminate
early admissions which came a week after
my book was published was at least in
part a response to some of the
revelations i have about harvard's
favoring the wealthy i mean i have some
interesting material in that chapter
including the fact that harvard has this
committee of 400 or 425 of its biggest
donors and about half of their children
have gone to harvard which is of course
a much higher rate than the one in 10
overall admissions rate so i think
harvard the timing of their decision to
eliminate early admissions may have had
something to do with my book otherwise
it depends a lot on whether the person
is a president of a college i examine or
not you know i've been given been given
many invitations to speak or talk to
presidents whose books were whose
schools were lucky enough not to be
mentioned in my book
one other point i might make about that
i don't think the moves by harvard and
princeton to eliminate early admissions
are all that significant you know they
were ballyhooed a great deal at the time
but
uh
it's an easier thing for them to do than
to eliminate preferences
so for harvard they were an early action
school which meant that you could always
you know if you didn't get into if you
got into harvard you could still apply
somewhere else so you could shop for the
best financial aid deal so it wasn't
clear their early admissions was hurting
low-income applicants
but since they still have these
preferences you know my guess is the
only thing that will happen is that
instead of admitting an alumni kid in
november they'll admit them in april and
so it's an easier move and less
offensive to their alumni and so on then
would be actually taking on these
preferences head on
yeah so you put a lot of the onus on
universities to to change their policies
but i was wondering if there's some way
that students could help out or other or
non-university actors could help make
this change and a second thing is um you
seem to
to advocate against all preference of
privilege in admissions and i was
wondering if you gave any thought to
low-income affirmative action or
something like that yeah let me let me
take the second question first because
it's fresher in my mind
and uh
yeah i i do believe in uh
preferences for people who are
disadvantaged i'm opposed to preferences
for the privileged but i believe in in
fundamentally an equal playing field so
let's say that you have an applicant who
is disadvantaged by race or by poverty
or by illness or because their families
moved a lot or they attended a
you know a very uh inadequate high
school
i think that should be taken into
consideration because ultimately
colleges want to
admit the students with the greatest
achievement or potential and a kids may
not have been able to fully realize
their potential because of one of these
disadvantages and in that situation i
certainly favor
giving preference to equalize the
playing field taking that disadvantage
into into account
now
what i'm what i oppose as i say is
preference for those who've already
received
every kind of advantage because by the
time you become
a get legacy preference or development
preference or preference because you're
a rower or a polo player or a squash
player think of all the other
preferences you've already had
essentially in your life probably gone
to a very good high school
probably had a tutoring or
other assistants probably had test
preparation for the sats or or other
standardized tests uh maybe even the
best you know preschool in elementary
school and middle school
and parents who are likely educated have
been able to afford travel and all sorts
of other resources so with all those
advantages
you know if you still can't
achieve enough to be admitted to a top
school without a big preference
once again then i don't think you
deserve to go
so
you know what the what we need to do is
level the playing field as much as
possible by taking away at least one
preference for the wealthy and taking
some of the disadvantages
of people who have not been able to show
their potential fully into account
yes
was any of this book motivated by your
own experience at harvard as an
undergraduate
uh that's a good question um
you know
it wasn't motivated by it in the sense
that i have no grievance or resentment
you know i enjoyed my time in college
very much
but
i was uh
aware
that there were some kids who had gotten
in
other ways than i did you know i i was
admitted on the basis of
meritocracy you know i was a strong
candidate i had no no harvard connection
uh so
i was aware that that wasn't true of
everybody
and i also you know as i think back on
my upbringing you know my parents were
both professors at umass
and i went to a public high school i
grew up in the environment of a public
university so i think i had a little of
coming an outsider's view of harvard
even while i was there and then while i
was there i also gained a certain
knowledge of it from an inside
perspective so i think both those things
benefited my ability to understand the
system and research this book sort of
the outside perspective coming from a
public school and public university
environment
and then the inside perspective of
actually being a student at harvard so
in those ways i think uh i was well
equipped to write a book like this
the price of admission
really favors the rich today
for a very obvious factor and it's
probably more or more overwhelming than
the rest of this that is the fact that
tuition rates have gone up so much
that now only the rich or the relatively
rich have access to pay the tuition fees
at the universities an example i went to
the
state university of new york one of the
campuses upstate when i went thousand
years ago the cost was practically zero
today that same university state
university supported by taxpayers costs
ten thousand dollars a year
at that time i couldn't if uh what i had
was nothing i could not have attended
the university so the rising tuition
rates i think fits into this outsole
right i mean you're right uh
high tuition rates obviously are a big
problem i don't spend a lot of time on
them in my book because
i don't have a lot new to say because
it's so obvious they're a problem um i
would say that of course for the it
really hurts the middle class right in
that in that if you're very low income
at least the elite schools uh you know
will give you
a lot of grants
there may be some loans but some schools
are saying they i think it's all grants
like like princeton uh but clearly if
you have a loan burden
that's uh that makes uh constricts your
choices for later life i'd also say that
you know colleges they love to boast
about being need blind
and that's true in a sense but they're
they're not wealth blind in that
obviously they reserve slots for the
wealthy so what that essentially means
is that with any individual student that
they accept who's low income they will
provide the the money to go to school
but they don't have room for a lot of
low-income students because they're
committed to admitting so many wealthy
students
so in the big picture they're very
neat and wealth conscious i would say
yes
successes of challenges to affirmative
action policies like in gratz and baccy
i was just wondering to what extent
these preferences have been legally
challenged and whether or not you think
they could be brought in a court
well that's yeah that's an interesting
question
this issue has come up a number of times
such as in the michigan case the
question being for those of you who
didn't hear it can you legally challenge
these kinds of preferences for the
wealthy
the answer seems to be no the reason
being that affirmative action is liable
to legal challenge because it's on the
surface of racial preference and the
constitution i'm not a lawyer but i know
the constitution is very strict about
the circumstances in which you can
favor one race over another
preferences like legacy preference or
development preference are not
on the surface racial preferences
because you could have a minority legacy
there are some children of minority uh
graduates
you could have a minority development
case or athlete in these sports so
the courts have pretty consistently held
that these are not racial preferences
that's kind of the difference between
league you know legalism and reality
because in reality you know legacies at
these schools are overwhelmingly white
and development cases are too and so are
the athletes in these sports if if you
remember that the duke lacrosse case a
few months ago uh people were shocked
that 46 out of the 47
players on the duke men's lacrosse team
turned out to be white and the three who
were
indicted
uh or at least charged i forget if they
were indicted we're all from private
schools you know expensive private high
schools and this is the pattern in these
in these sports actually that there's
overwhelming
overwhelmingly white and so uh you know
there's a gap between reality and uh law
and
this gentleman over here had asked a
question that bears on yours which is
what can students do about this
there's not really a legal remedy but
you know there have been political
attempts over the years to try and uh
restrict or get rid of uh some of these
preferences senator kennedy who in fact
the harvard legacy himself
filed uh a bill kind of a sunshine bill
to bring more information about legacy
preference to light a couple years ago
it didn't go anywhere
partly because and this is one of the
problems i mean all the polls show that
the american public is uh heavily
opposed to legacy preference the
american public wants equality and
admissions but uh
the trouble is that the elites all
benefit from these preferences so you
know for example in the last 20 30 years
there's been a huge growth in earmarked
funding from congress so what happens is
a politician will work the system so
that five million dollars or ten million
dollars or twenty million dollars goes
to a particular school for
you know a new laboratory a new uh a new
building a new project
and as i document my book you know lo
and behold a couple years later that
politicians children go to that college
or the children of a key constituent or
a key staff member so politicians
benefit from this system they work it
they get favors just like businessmen
just like uh
entertainers and celebrities just like
alumni of all kinds who are well off
so uh
the problem is is that it's very hard
for the people to make their will known
over the the voices of the elites on
this issue
yes
at yale for example over half of
undergraduates come from public schools
so students from lower and middle income
backgrounds are getting in do you think
that our society has anything
to benefit from these types of students
socializing with and and being educated
with those more acquainted with the
culture of power and influence
i see your point i think i don't know
the yale statistics i do remember uh
hearing at harvard that 55 of the
students are from public schools and 45
are from private schools so that's
obviously a much greater private school
representation than you would have among
all high school graduates so it's still
heavily weighted toward private schools
in uh in proportional terms and i would
imagine yale is somewhat the same way i
also think that the other 55 who go to
public school come from public schools
and again i'm talking i know harvard
better than yale
that doesn't necessarily mean they're
lower middle income because a lot of
them are coming from
excellent suburban public high schools
whether in you know scarsdale or lake
forest or illinois or or you know
suburban suburbia all over so so i
wouldn't say that 55 percent of them are
coming from you know low-income
households but uh
as to whether there's a benefit from
mixing with the children of leaders
i mean if you're a yale undergraduate
you tell me i mean my experience and
what people have told me is there may
not be that much mixing you know there's
i almost felt there was kind of
uh and people have told me that there's
almost two worlds at some of the elite
colleges
where uh
you know for example at princeton with
its uh eating clubs or harvard with its
finals clubs those are predominantly
where the children of the rich join and
network and i know at princeton for
example asian american students have
complained about being shut out of the
eating club so
i don't know if they would benefit if
there's a lot of mingling
but i'm not sure there really is that
much
interconnection and
exchange of ideas and opening up of
minds and that kind of thing
but you might know better than me
because it's been a long time since i
was in college
you were asked before if you had heard
from any of the administrators have you
heard from any of the parents or
students
well uh i've heard from a few of them on
a
you know
background basis where i don't feel free
to divulge their names but i've had a
number of uh students of wealth and
privilege saying you know you were right
about me
you know and i feel guilty about it i'm
going to work later in life to display a
social conscience so
uh obviously that's not the universal
view i'm sure
many of them are
not too happy with my book
but uh
you know in a way
when the journal articles came out uh
there was more of a battle you know
because my approach then was was new and
fresh and uh
unproven
and i think uh
you know once my article articles came
out you know i won a pulitzer for them
i think
it was sort of generally conceded that
at least i had the right to explore this
terrain
and so i haven't heard a lot of uh
protests but
you know i'm sure they're out there and
there are places where i would not
exactly be made welcome where i
to go knock on the door
well thank you all very much i've
enjoyed it very much nice talking to you
[Applause]
daniel golden was awarded the pulitzer
prize in 2004 for his reports on
preferences for privileged applicants at
elite colleges
currently he's deputy bureau chief at
the wall street journal's boston bureau
you can find the wall street